7 février 1992 douze pays européens
signent le traité de maastricht un acte
fondateur de l'union européenne le
traité d'union européenne un pavé de
quelques 320 pages négocié pendant plus
de 30 heures au dernier sommet de
maastricht début décembre et qui a été
toilettée comme on dit sur le plan
juridique pendant six semaines par les
spécialistes au programme du nouveau
pavé européens un projet de monnaie
unique une politique étrangère et de
sécurité commune une coopération
policière et judiciaire
et surtout le traité de maastricht
consacre la citoyenneté européenne
on reste français anglais ou italien
mais on est tout autant citoyens de
l'union la citoyenneté européenne
devient l'un des enjeux majeurs de
l'union objectifs des pays membres
renforcer l'identité commune et faire
adhérer la population au projet
politique européen tout ressortissant de
l'un des 12 pays de la communauté pourra
voter pour les élections européennes ou
municipales dans le pays où ils résident
un allemand en france un français en
italie et c'est être citoyen européen
c'est donc se mobiliser pour l'union en
clair voter
mais il ya bien un scrutin qui ne
mobilise pas les foules ce sont les
élections européennes et la france n'y
échappe pas écoutez je rapporte
aujourd'hui telle europe entre 1979
année de la première élection et 2014 le
taux d'abstention n'a fait qu'augmenter
en europe pourtant des campagnes de pub
se multiplier pour inciter à voter en
vain et j'ai pas été mis au courant tout
simplement jeu totalement et du coup
j'ai pas été fair la carte d'électeur en
2019 la tendance s'inverse et le taux
d'abstention recule de huit points sept
allemands se réjouissait et évoqué un
sentiment européen
[Musique]
citoyenneté européenne et rimerait donc
avec fierté européenne un sentiment
toujours aussi marqué aujourd'hui chez
les allemands 78% d'entre eux se disent
fiers d'être européen contre 68% des
français
[Musique]